whatever is begun in anger ends in shame
i didn't fail the test i just
found 100 ways to do it wrong
life's biggest tragedy is that we
get old too soon and wise too late
there are three faithful friends an
old wife an old dog and ready money
never leave till tomorrow
that which you can do today
time is money
well done is better than well said
no gains without pains
one today is worth two tomorrows
laziness travels so slowly
that poverty soon overtakes him
rather go to bed without
dinner than to rise in debt
at 20 years of age the will reigns
at 30 the wit and at 40 the judgment
to succeed jump as quickly at
opportunities as you do at conclusions
lost time is never found again
an investment in knowledge pays the best interest
where there is marriage without love
there will be love without marriage
haste makes waste
if a man empties his purse into his
head no one can take it from him
three may keep a secret if two of them are dead
many people die at 25 and
aren't buried until they are 75
never ruin an apology with an excuse
he that lies down with dogs
shall rise up with fleas
doused thou love life then do not squander
time for that's the stuff life is made of
educate your children to self-control to
the habit of holding passion and prejudice
and evil tendencies subject to an upright and
reasoning will and you have done much to abolish
misery from their future and crimes from society
keep your eyes wide open before
marriage half shut afterwards
we do not stop playing because we grow
old we grow old because we stop playing
work as if you were to live a thousand
years play as if you were to die tomorrow
contentment makes poor men rich
discontent makes rich men poor
beware of little expenses a
small leak will sink a great ship
you will find the key to
success under the alarm clock
vice knows that he is ugly so he puts on a mask
having been poor is no shame
but being ashamed of it is
if you would know the value of
money go and try to borrow some
he that displays too often his wife and his wallet
is in danger of having both of them borrowed
fatigue is the best pillow
the discontented man finds no easy chair
to find out a girl's faults
praise her to her girlfriends
love your enemies for they tell you your faults
buy what thou hast no seed of and air
long thou shalt sell thy necessities
you may delay but time will not which
quote did you like the most share your
opinion in the comments don't miss out on
a chance to see the next video subscribe